was he intense with you did he want did
he was he intense as a director because
he wanted you to feel that or not at all
no he spoke very little didn't talk
about story he didn't talk about acting
didn't talk about the scene never
nothing ever ever how many times
the most I did was nine and that was for
the blanket party when they put the soap
in the towels and beat me up what I mean
all you hear is 100 takes 90 takes 50
doors he didn't do that with other
people but not with us not with Matthew
and I Matthew Matthew Arliss and and
their team when they were doing the
Vietnam stuff they got stuck behind that
wall there's a wall that they're behind
before they go into the village right at
the end when the sniper gets right at
the end of the first act when the sniper
second act when the sniper gets killed
remember all those guys get shot in that
one little area they were behind that
wall for I believe around four months so
and it was merely because of the way
Stanley made movies you know he was very
different than anybody I've ever worked
with before